you say cyrus et ne savent pas dans un
coup de fil nous sommes dans une vidéo
spéciale bac
alors quand même le coup de fil c'est
pas une chaîne juste pour éviter la
philo c'est une chaîne qui va qui a
introduit des concepts philosophiques
d'une manière si possible drôle fn mais
de fait et beaucoup de gens qui en fait
sur le coup de fil en rapport avec le
bac de philo donc pour ces gens là j'ai
fait une vidéo spéciale baky qu'est ce
donc cette vidéo pour les autres vu que
vous êtes venu avec une tête une soif de
philosophie voici une vidéo je trouvais
intéressante de gibert riches sur les
diversités donc allez-y regarder et pour
ceux qui restent et là c'est parti
le bac de philo alors déjà tout ce qui
est moindre vis pas je vais l'aider au
talent non maman le talent ça marche
bien genre pas déjà si tu en as y
termine pas ça marche bien pour refaire
un temps bleus pas ton premier rapport
sexuel des choses comme ça le bac de
philo ça marche pas trop les lots talent
pourquoi parce que bon on va pas
seulement analyser ou jugés dont la
manière d'avoir une réflexion ton effort
de penser comme et disant programme on
va aussi voir tes connaissances
on va aussi vérifier que pendant les
heures de philo tu étais pas au fond de
la classe en train de jouer avec
indiquera futur donc n'y allez pas aux
talents à la limite vous pouvez y aller
en talons mais en allant vers visé quoi
archipel j'ai lu des trucs genre voilà
la mdr moi je vais aller complètement
fons des eaux et tue des fonds sera un
autre jour longue errance pas parce que
le bac de philo c'est mois de juin que
vous voyez les compléments fons des noms
mais on va juger et tout ce que tu as
fait en philo en quatre heures et le
bouton recommencer et il prend un an
pas de bêtises quoi ensuite
le plus important pour moi c'est
vraiment la première impression
la première impression que tu vas donner
quand je rencontre quelqu'un dans la rue
à waimes qui te parle
il va faire une première impression
genre si le mec il a des chaussettes
avec des sandales des questions directes
va donner les premières impressions de
merde et ça va être chaud produit de
rattraper cette première impression pour
y mater copie de philo c'est à peu près
la même chose sur la première impression
ça va être ton écriture tu vois c'est un
joli les ratures l'orthographe et ses
toiles en eau le point de philosophie
voilà les affaires on bosse à
versailles la première impression
déjà les ratures il y en hd ils sont en
mode avec leur type et ondées valérie
damidot tuffal l'art déco une autre fois
en garde là on est là pour pour être
efficace quoi au truc super important de
morteau graff l'orthographe c'est
vraiment le truc qui va vous su toute
votre vie prenez le comme comme une
matière en elle même point
jouer les commentaires youtube quand il
ya un gars qui a une argumentation mais
qui a un marteau grave pourri c'est
difficile de prendre au sérieux
pas moi je parle même pas de ceux qui
répondent etc
ils sont là en train de corriger les
fautes doivent être souples ce même pas
parler français
enfin bref ça a clashé tout mais je me
dis que c'est quand même une grosse
forme de discrimination l'orthographe
donc vraiment travailler ça on va
maintenant rentrer dans le coeur du
sujet il ya deux existe différents et le
premier exercice et la dissertation avec
deux sujets au choix un temps fait qu'un
seul type a le dessus j'ai déjà un ça
suffit généralement on va voir ça en
trois étapes et tapez 1 tapez
problématique en gros tu à ton sujet tu
vas essayer de faire sortir une question
un problème peut-être même un paradoxe
lié à ce sujet et tu vas le formuler 15
étapes 1 étape 2 tu vas faire ton
plancton plonge vraiment eu trop
brouillons la partie 1 ça va être la
moins philosophique le sens commun et ça
va jusqu'aux plus philosophique dans la
partie 3 ok généralement on parle du
plan on parle pas mal de plans
dialectique le plan dialectique c'est
thèse antithèse synthèse ont une action
un peu réticent appeler ça comme ça et
pas plus à un test de tech3 rapporte
généralement ça se regroupent plutôt pas
mal en gros à quoi ça consiste en quoi
cela consiste t deux premières parties
en route us étaient deux premières
thèses et voit un petit peu se
contredire ok et là on galère tous c'est
pour la troisième thèse et là j'ai chopé
une citation de gilles vervisch dans
l'étudiant point com qui dit l'étudiant
points comme que je conseille grave rien
c'est très cher oui enfin il ya pas mal
de conseils notamment sur le bac sur
toutes les filières est donc n'hésitez
pas à cliquer pour toutes les matières
il faut trouver le présupposé commun aux
deux premières thèses donc
c'est à dire ce en quoi la thèse et
l'antithèse s'accordent ils rajoutent
déconstruisent et ce présupposé pour
dégager une troisième thèse ne reposant
pas sur celui ci
en gros cette troisième thèse dite
synthèse elle va céder des deux
premières se poster au dessus des
précieux a en moins dans la tête ça
donne un truc genre
c'est sa première thèse attente attente
suite à la question c'est ça vaut la
peine
mais en fait c'est aussi sa deuxième
thèse quand je regarde c'est de trucs là
je me dis que finalement c'est sa
troisième je le vois comme ça se passe
comme ça dans la tête
donc j'appelle peut-être que ça va
t'aider l'étape 3 cruciale aussi c'est
en mots le développement tu vas passer
des idées qui sont sur griffonné sur un
bout de papier à ta vraie copie de philo
qui comme on l'a dit doit donner une
première impression qui ronge actuelle
donc très important en toi tu passe
vraiment du temps dessus il y en a qui
sortent au bout de deux heures ouais
ouais
laisse tomber mon gars je suis trop fort
je fais le truc en deux heures le 4-1
généralement si tu avais truc en 2h08 4
c'est qu'il ya un problème on passe à
côté d'un truc aussi à mon professeur de
philo de terminale
patricia doc ans que je salue et que je
remercie
on m'a donné l'amour de la philo qui
disait que ceux qui passent la grecque
de philo donc les futurs profs de philo
donc à une série de sept heures ils font
pas cette heure parce que il pense au
ralenti donc l'argument de dire je fais
vite si j'étais vite c'est parce que je
suis je pense super vite
non tu penses que les futurs profs de
philo il pense pas puisque toi moyen des
fous quoi donc
vraiment passer du temps et même si tu
imagines tu es super fort tu as fait ton
truc en deux heures et son truc et bien
faire deux fois mieux mais c'était déjà
c'était était resté deux heures de plus
dans tous les cas ça pourrit toi ok donc
super importante qui penche sur les
références moi je fais des vidéos sur
internet donc sert que je peux parler à
propos de tout ce que je veux des films
geek des comics émission télé réalité
n'importe quoi toi c'est pas le cas
d'ailleurs j'ai reçu des messages de
personnes qui ont eu à jessica harry
potter je me suis fait défoncer voilà je
suis désolé essayer de rester le plus
classique possible donc si vous trouvez
un truc qui n'est pas dans une oeuvre en
plus ça veut dire que c'est order donc
laissé tomber passer directement au plat
principal
on a sauté avec lui merci non plus
sérieusement
construisez vous de vraies références
solides classique
regardez aussi les news sociétale les
news scientifique pour essayer de voir
ce qui pouvait pas mettre des trucs en
rapport à l'actualité etc
moi j'essaie d'en regrouper dans vos
pages facebook facebook pardon le coup
de fil que je vous conseille d'aller
checker pour l'expliquer son texte voici
une vidéo super cool qui dure 45 minutes
donc ça c'est long et ça explique heures
en profondeur le truc en gros déjà ce
que tu vas devoir faire c'est résumer la
thèse des régies attestent de l'auteur
en résumant sa pensée et pour ça il faut
que tu comprennes vraiment le texte si
t'arrives pas à le faire c'est que t'as
pas compris donc relire le texte
si tu leur lit plus de 30 fois et tu as
toujours pas compris fait la différence
un certain conseil peut-être que le
texte n'est pas fait pour toi
ensuite j'ai dû tranche par tranche on y
est fait de l'émincé de poulet sur le
texte tu vois ligne par ligne et
explique ce que le mec expliqué
en gros tu fais une sorte de coup de fil
en peut-être
plus sérieux et avec des exemples est
tous d'accord tu expliques les notions
et explique les connecteurs logique et
homps lancé le plan du texte c est juste
et vite la paraphrase la paraphrase en
fait c'est tu vas pas ces genres tu fais
genre tu expliques mais en fait tu tues
reformule simplement
donc ça c'est vraiment un truc que tu
dois éviter pour l'éviter n'hésite pas
j'en discutais la thèse de l'auteur
essaie de voir l'intérêt du texte pour
la question de donner son avis ou non
une bonne copie de philo on ne sait pas
de quel avis il est lire donc la réponse
est non ce n'est pas censé donner ton
avis après est ce que c'est bien ce que
c'est mal parce que c'est cool on n'est
pas là pour se poser ce genre de
questions tu vois on est là pour avoir
une bonne note
et pour avoir une bonne note pas faux
pas des lyonnais ils vont prendre des
vacances et où justement posé dans les
notes et y en a pour qui parle de
loterie en philo alors c'est faux mais
pas complètement je m'explique en gros
moi je considère donc c'est mon avis
c'est mon avis je concède sa marche par
palier suivant la qualité ta copie et
l'appréciation du correcteur optio en
gros une bonne copie elle ira entre 16
et 23 mai entre vaulx jazz c'est entre
16 et 20 très mauvaise copie elle n'aura
jamais au dessus d'une certaine date
donc ça marche un peu par paliers donc
toi ton but c'est d'avoir le meilleur
payet possible et ensuite c'est mon avis
c'est comme ça que
je me recentre pour les révisions moi je
vous conseille les fiches par notion les
fiches par émotion parce qu'en fait du
coup dès qu'il ya une notion qui pop up
dans dans la dissert tu vas essayer de
voir dans ta fiche ok alors il s'agit de
dire çà çà çà machin et voir en gros ce
qui est pertinent ou pas le but c'est
pas tous sortir et faire un catalogue
ikea n'est pas un marchand de citations
tu vois c'est vraiment d'être pertinents
dernière chose utilisent les autres
matières que tu vois dans ta filière
comme bagage pour ta disserte pour coter
exemple de philo quoi genre par exemple
c'était ans elle va chercher des trucs
dans les agro littéraire tu vas t en s
n'hésite pas à utiliser ce que tu as
appris en sciences en série de la terre
quoi c'est un bs pareil peut-être la
culture & co etc etc voilà généralement
vous prenez pas trop la tête pour le bac
au pire si vous le ratez vous raté votre
vie enfin c'est bien pire que ça on
pourrait par exemple moi je trouve là
comme ça je trouve pas mais je pense
qu'à pierre voilà non mais enfin
ouais enfin on veut dire bonne chance
je sais pas pourquoi je suis pas pro fin
du tout du tout du tout du tout c'est
juste un mec qui est bien la fille
lotoil aura tous que ce que j'ai pris et
j'ai pris à droite à gauche etc
mais je n'ai pas envie que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup d'entre
vous qui m ont passé le bac et zou donc
ça me ferait plaisir que
que je vous aide d'une manière ou d'une
autre donc voilà j'espère que ça vous a
aidé et un truc super important aussi
même quand le mec est passée la comptine
sud le coup de fil parce que si on la
prend de la philo si on peut la philo
c'est pas que en vue du bac c'est aussi
pour avoir différentes perspectives sur
différentes choses et c'est rare
c'est intéressant en soi donc vraiment
continuer et moi je vous dis bon chance
ouais tu vois c'est éclat dans leurs
yeux rockets avoir notre combat je me
suis entraîné à fond mais j'avais pas ce
regard là toi tu l'avais et tu as gagné
il faut que tu retrouves ce regard-là
l'oeil du tigre mec
oui il a eu du tigre